et le constat est sans appel sur la
dérive de ce que nous appelons un coup
politique ce jeudi la commission
d'enquête du Sénat a rendu ses
conclusions sur la gestion troubles du
fond Marianne et des 2,5 millions
d'euros dont il était doté à l'origine
au cœur de la tourmente Marlène Schiappa
alors secrétaire d'État à la citoyenneté
elle est pointée du doigt pour avoir
mise en place un dispositif ou règne le
manque de rigueur l'opacité et la
désinvolture qui ont conduit au fiasco
mise en place en 2021 à la suite de
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty par un jeune
radicalisé le fond Marianne était censé
soutenir financièrement des associations
qui luttent contre les discours haineux
et séparatistes sur les réseaux sociaux
mais à la suite de plusieurs articles et
reportages pointant les faibles
réalisations de certaines associations
lauréat du fond le Sénat a ouvert en mai
une commission pour faire la lumière sur
le mécanisme d'attribution des
subventions publiques le parquet
national financier a également ouvert
une enquête début mai pour détournement
de fonds publics par négligence abus de
confiance et prise illégale d'intérêt en
ligne de mire l'Union des sociétés
d'éducation physique de préparation
militaire qui a raflé un budget de
355000 euros grâce à un contrat conclu
en amont de la clôture des appels
d'offres et pour un résultat plus que
mitigé la commission sénatoriale a
révélé que 87% des subventions avaient
été utilisées pour des dépenses de
personnel avec infinie un résultat bien
décevant en terme de contenu 451
communication sur différents comptes 8
articles sur un site Internet lors de
son audition au Sénat le 14 juin la
secrétaire d'État avait cherché à se
décharger de toute responsabilité en
mettant en cause son cabinet dans le
processus de sélection sans toutefois
convaincre la commission je réponds pour
ce que j'ai fait je n'ai pas
connaissance d'autres échanges
personnels mais l'ija et vous même et
peut-être la justice le diront mais moi
je suis formelle je vous le dis sousment
je n'ai à aucun moment demandé ou passer
commande à ce que Monsieur cifaoui soit
priorisé ou mis au dessus de la pile je
n'avais aucune raison de le faire et je
ne l'ai pas fait autre soupçon Marlène
Schiappa aurait siamois retiré de la
liste des lauréats SOS Racisme en raison
de contentieux personnel avec son
président Marlène Schiappa a
manifestement eu un choix guidé par une
acrimonie personnelle à mon endroit
cette attitude des notes un rapport pour
le moins abusif au pouvoir les
conclusions de l'enquête du Sénat sont
sans appel le cabinet de la ministre et
la ministre délégué en outrepassé leur
rôle depuis les appels à démission se
multiplient le président du groupe LR au
Sénat Bruno Retailleau a notamment
déploré de voir la lutte contre le
séparatisme entaché par des coups de
Come des règlements de compte personnels
et des bases droits